hey we're having an emergency down at
the Deerfield Motel can you please put
me through to the police station no no
cops no cops uh
just for the storm they're probably so
busy with the snow plows and the snow
things
yeah
probably right I don't think they could
even get through with the roads closed
yeah I saw a bunch of guys shutting down
the road to Denver it is bad
why were you driving my car to Denver
to look for you
silly you stole my car
you [__] klepto hippie freak okay you
don't need to get weird about it Morty
look me in the eyes did you or any of
your Associates run me over so you could
steal my car
no
all right
a man wallet
ladies the closest Clinic is in Avon
over the past I think it's too dangerous
to get you there tonight so how about
this Jimmy sets you up with a room you
clean up that leg get some rest gratis
Gratis yeah let's figure this all out in
the morning can you walk ah [__]
probably yeah
oh big Arthur that [__] hurts I can
make a split do this all the time I just
stick and make it half the size oh no
that's an NT I'll buy you another
antique all right guys because we can
just use my stabby stick where is it
it's uh it's actually exactly the
perfect size
some more [__]
it that is not a stick
yeah that's bone
get that thing I don't know in the uh
the place I woke up and the tree thing
out in the woods you know there's animal
bones everywhere out there
no way dude
that is a person bone congratulations
because I think you found a fossil
that's like Paleolithic or something
from a caveman it could be no that
Bone's not old it's got metal pins in it
so that's surgical right
whoa I know what this is
suddenly bonologists here oh my God
terrible had a gnarly half pipe crash
and they did surgery and put pins in his
legs and he showed me the x-rays and
they looked just
like that
Morty uh you and me at stance that sign
with the snowboarding girl who went
missing the one you see all over town
right does that sound familiar well yes
because you were there come on bus stops
Burger Kings everywhere you go you see
that that flyer with their face on it uh
you guys know what I'm talking about
right she's got a catchy name like a
Jackie jazz or Claudia the the hotel
must have one of those missing posters
right
[__]
why would you lie about that
I know exactly why
because there was a reward 75
000 see I do remember it's very Sharpie
here is lying because he wants the
reward all to himself what the [__] dude
Jesus yes I have one
oh
hey look Morty are you thinking what I'm
thinking
we found Chloe Jones hey hey chances
that it's this girl I mean what are we
even talk and talk about here and we
still can't do anything about it until
tomorrow morning Jimmy get the rooms
ready the motel's empty we're gonna give
you the best rooms in the place that are
exactly the same as all the other rooms
come on
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no